j'aime vraiment ça nous fait plaisir de
voir de vous parler donc je me demandais
on était d'attirer avec c'est difficile
bataille que vous venez en ce moment
mais merci d'abord être remis dans
beaucoup de pays ça peut bien ça va bien
rire quand il considère en trois petits
points c'est ça que je suis un
traitement je vais la journée des
traitements et le lendemain se
précipitent ici mais ça va relativement
bien
je pense que le fait que j'arrêtais
travailler sur un champ en congé ça fait
en sorte que je peux vraiment me reposer
davantage je me rends compte aujourd'hui
à quel point j'étais fatigué quel point
j'étais lélé lafrique
et ce qui est particulier lors de
situations c'est que vous êtes une femme
très sportif très active il n'avait
jamais fait non
battait contre un cancer
du poumon de ce que j'ai appris en fait
piètre de corsair discours moyenne qu'un
soft phone - défouloir et le cancer du
foie qui provoque un tacle les
non-fumeurs des gens qui n'ont jamais
fumé blog moi je n'ai jamais fumé de ma
vie je le veux pas
j'ai jamais rien pris d'autre
j'étais excessivement sportives
auxquelles il faisait beaucoup de sport
d'ailleurs mon exutoire dans tous les
procès conduits dans ma carrière c'était
le score pour la chaîne de deuil qui
fait le deuil de mon de ma carrière
politique et je fais le deuil de ma
carrière de la maison de mon
environnement sportif parce que je
faisais tout l'espoir donc j'imagine
qu'elle n'était pas intéressée
trotteront à la campagne électorale qui
s'en vient c'est ceux de famille et elle
essaie quand même parce que bon car
hélas mon quart et avec tous les
collèges collègues d'écouter mes
collègues ministres donc c'est ce que je
vais enlever une porte attention il
disait que j ai mis beaucoup ce que vous
avez fait est ce que vous avez
l'impression commandes de l'équipe et
vous avez accompli ce que j'ai apprécié
oui parce que je vais jouer j'ai fait un
bon tour de table je suis satisfait de
ce que j'ai fait aucun avec un national
avec les ministères des relations
internationales si dans le comté mais je
pense qu'on a mis des très très bonne
base pour plusieurs choses vous avez
parlé la virage économique est ce que ça
veut dire on parce que qu'est-ce que ça
change pour les délégations du québec et
ça change beaucoup parce qu'une
délégation du québec avant que j'arrive
avant de travailler bien peu de 2018
délégation du québec serait en fait
davantage sur de la discrimation
défiance est d'être une assise sociale
donc il y avait à dire dire une petite
partie qui étaient plus des interactions
avec les consuls avec les avec les
ministres avec c'est beaucoup moins
orienté économique donc comme un chiffre
d'affaires en forte il ya plusieurs
personnes à les clients d dénégations
qui ont changé on a mis des gens qui
avaient des profils beaucoup plus
économique mais capable aussi d'abord
cela engage dans les gens d'affaires
parce que l'objectif était de développer
les affaires avec les différents pays
pour faire peur et c'est ce que les pays
veulent beaucoup plus qu'ils écoutent et
on file des français ont fait affaire
avec le chinois ont fait affaire mais on
n'y est pas on voit pas les québécois
ont vu qu'on va faire avec des québécois
et c'est ce qu'on a développée avec la
tv le virage il a été un gros changement
les délégations et donc ça ça donne quoi
des contrats veut plus de lui quand on
voit des boues contraint par exemple
concept c'est comme hydro québec mais
s'ils en contractent les autobus ou lyon
tout se contrôle à son travail et à la
base par les délégations sont signés au
niveau des deux carabines économies mais
ils sont travaillés par les délégations
pour ce genre de contrat ce sont des
contrats de travail sur des lois et des
fois des amis j'en ai quand même eu tout
un party aura quand on regarde nos
parents ont quitté haïti d'appui aux
missions ryad et grandit en gaspésie
pour vous retrouver éventuellement
ministre dans un gouvernement legault
c'est exceptionnel a été difficile pour
vous de faire votre place oui et non
puisque j'ai quelqu'un qui pense
beaucoup les enquêtes y aime les défis
donc j'ai toujours cherché des défis
différents pire même temps mais quand on
cherchait des pubs et tout ça tombe
dessus et avoir des avoirs des obstacles
et avoir des enjeux qui est capable de
passer par dessus et j'ai toujours été
quelqu'un de très fort et c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça marche sur ce
parcours là parce que j'ai fait de
superbes en son intérieur et ce poste de
minus laquelle j'ai versé pour le député
de ministre j'ai l'impression que c'est
toutes les pointes de tarbes de ma
carrière qui te des points de tables
différentes qu'on avait mis ensemble
qu'elle a maintenant la javel à porto
confié j'ai fait vraiment son ex pour
une enfant d'origine haïtienne dans une
petite vieille coque d'acier vous avez
grandi là vous avez été dit à la télé
on était plus mes chouchous on était
très peu de familles haïtiennes pensons
et tête de samuel siens j'en étais la
curiosité
avec moi j'étais très prévention je n'ai
aucun souvenir négatif de gasquet qui
était accueilli dans la classe de
maternelle je suis la première fois
qu'on est rentré à l'école on m'a
présenté ma petite amie à côté de moi
qui s'appelait louis et aujourd'hui il
est encore mon ami
fait malgré tout on entend un moment les
difficultés et on peut avoir lieu si oui
comment vous êtes consciente on a eu les
c du tout à fait consciente on a vécu
pourquoi pourquoi s'ils arrivent à se
cacher à feliciano plus là les défis des
commentaires jean marc planus il quand
je me suis présenté
ici dans le comté de bertren il y avait
des commentaires mais bon emplacement de
ses filles la preuve que c'était quatre
ans plus tard on m'a élu j'ai une grosse
majorité
qu'est ce que vous avez comme une star
âge pour les petits jeunes qui rentrent
là qui sont leur première campagne
électorale
sauter ça vaut la peine de s'y ça fait
peur
et moi j'ai pris beaucoup de temps afin
de la décision jacqueline de celle qu'on
a dû appeler qu'on a dit à qui on a dit
parler de nombreuses reprises savoir que
je dise oui parce que bon la politique
bon je la suivais mais de loin mais je
vous dis allusif ça vaut vraiment la
peine que c'est vraiment là qu'on peut
faire changer les choses qui se faisait
à porter depuis la politique cela
m'importe est la proximité avec les gens
de nous amuser les gens quittent alors
là bonjour comment ça va donc les gens
gens nous reconnaissent des gens
apprécient ils apprécient le fait qu'on
soit présent pour eux c'est très très
apprécié et donc là et cette campagne
qui s'amorce
cela vous manquer énormément énormément
mois d'août et je ne me gêne pas de
questions dans ma tête leur présenter
c'était certes un certain certains
c'était une évidence t'es même pas un
questionnement c'était une évidence
d'ailleurs j'ai pris beaucoup de temps
décidé à ne pas me présenter parce que
chaque jour vous salue bien dormi et je
la force pour le faire le lendemain de
retomber donc c'était très long a pris
ma décision mais je protège mon choix
qui veut vraiment de la santé vis ici le
championnat si le tout seul je vais
vraiment que je prenne pied du massif
il voulait simplement
moi la suite
et surtout faire en sorte que je passe
au travers tous ces traitements leur que
j'ai assez de force pour passer au
travers
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'énergie dont je
suis ont récupéré idéalement j'aimerais
bien recommencer à faire un peu de sport
parce que ça c'est une
grande peine pour moi donc j'aimerais
beaucoup bossé dur commençait à faire un
peu de sport n'est pas assez j'ai pas pu
faire beau ce qui fait que j'ai demandé
qu'on transfère ma passe de ce qu'elle
cette année
alors cette année j'ai appris que je
puisse faire un petit ce qui
conférera une journée à la fois c'est
vraiment ça fait donc je ne suis pas
quelqu'un de très près patients
j'aiguise et j'aiguise beaucoup
d'impatience
on vous souhaite
en juin mais du courage aussi merci
beaucoup juste et qu'ils en avaient
merci j'avais un mercenaire gates est
vraiment plaisir